this week
on brian ross investigates covent
quackery crackdown
the feds move in to shut down a
so-called church that claims it has a
cure using bleach for cloven 19
and wanted president trump's blessing mr
president
please we just want the right to choose
but it's self-proclaimed archbishop has
been offering the same bleach concoction
for years
as a treatment for autism cancer and
heart disease
critics asking why it took so long to
finally stop it
plus the 2020 election are long lines
fewer polling places and mayhem ahead
one investigative reporter says trump
and the republicans
are already busy stealing the election
this is going to be a disaster come
november unless
we prepare and this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the editors of
mediaite
about their choices we don't endorse
those words
they have no connection to the show from
the law and crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigate
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on youtube
live and facebook live i'm joined
tonight by my colleague at the law and
crime network rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with a crackdown on
covet 19
quackery for years a man by the name of
mark grenon has been offering what he
calls
a miracle mineral solution that he says
cures autism
cancer heart disease alzheimer's and
most recently
cloven 19. in fact authorities say it's
nothing more than
industrial bleach but granite has been
getting away with it runner for years
because he claims he's the archbishop of
a church he founded genesis 2
and that he's protected by the first
amendment distributing this cure as a
kind of sacrament
that's right brian and last april the
federal government ordered mark brennan
and the genesis church to stop
selling this so-called miracle cure but
they didn't stop
and last week federal agents moved in to
shut down
shut down their operation in florida
it was a big rate in fact reporters
covering it saw federal agents taking
away
barrels full of chemicals
a tampa area man and his three sons are
facing federal charges this morning
they're accused of selling a counterfeit
cure for the coronavirus
and other diseases the criminal
complaint says the bleach-like mixture
billed as miracle mineral solution was
sold nationwide through an
outfit called the genesis 2 church of
healthy and healing
federal agents raided a bradenton home
that investigators say has been the
distribution site
for a potentially harmful solution
called genesis mms
marketed as a miracle treatment for
coronavirus
four men mark grenon and sons jonathan
jordan and joseph are accused of telling
people to drink that solution which
turns into
a powerful bleach that could be fatal
they were ordered to stop selling their
toxic bleach solution
marketed as a coronavirus cure in april
since then the church has continued to
sell the substance
even sending letters to the judge
overseeing the case
saying they would not comply and
threatening violence
right now 34-year-old jonathan grenon
and 26-year-old jordan grenin are being
held
on a u.s marshall hold at the pinellas
county jail
jonathan and jordan grenon behind bars
following their arrest
on wednesday in connection to the raid
at their church
thousands of pounds of evidence were
confiscated
but the archbishop himself mark brennan
has fled the country
he's in colombia where this week he was
interviewed by mike adams of natural
news
a very sympathetic interview getting
grenan's view of what happened
mark grenon is currently in colombia and
he expects to be arrested and
extradited at any moment he joins us now
with an emergency
message for health freedom mark thank
you for joining me today
mike i really appreciate you um having
us on today because it's very important
for
for all of us and for the world um we uh
we're just going through it we've been
going through it for three months with
these people
really 10 years this is as of april 8th
they sent us a warning that we should
stop
um based upon what the fda says we the
fda sent us to warning we should stop
giving our sacraments to the world so
we just basically said no we have the
first to write first amendment which is
i was
it's right up here i don't know if you
could see it too good but
it's right up there it says we have the
exercise the free exercise
our religious beliefs
according federal court documents
granted made last year a half million
dollars selling this
industrial bleach as a cure for all
these diseases
and it's been hardly a secret that for
years he's been doing this he's been the
subject of a number of investigative
reports
including one that rhonda schwarzenegger
did at 2020 of abc news
are you harmless people do you think
with this sir no you're not
not at all no can you stand by that this
can cure
all these diseases and you honestly
believe this can cure cancer you're an
actor okay i'm a reporter a piece
of they say in spanish but just just
just leave
go check out the facts okay our
[Music]
so the question now for many critics of
mark grenon and his
miracle cure is why did it take so long
we're joined by
fiona o'leary from county cork in
ireland who for years has been trying to
get the attention of authorities to
crack down
fiona thank you for joining us now that
he is a fugitive do you think he's going
to stop
no i don't because the genesis ii church
do not believe in the law and they do
not follow the law
they think they're a church and that
they don't have to answer to them all
and i really fear that mark graham won't
be arrested
um like his sons have been and that he
will hide out in colombia where he's
living i believe at the moment
and um he's only one of many i just want
to make that clear these arrests are
important but there are hundreds of
people doing this as we speak
mostly um in south america especially in
ecuador where his colleague
andreas calker is making
this as a miracle cure for covert as we
speak and there are thousands of people
being experimented on with bleach as we
speak
so this scam continues to spread around
the world a fiona according to court
documents it actually has caused death
and made several people ill
what do you know about that i'm aware of
that for many years now i've been
campaigning against the genesis 2 for
seven years
i do this on a voluntary basis and i am
outraged at this stage because
the fda did know about the grenades
factory
in florida they knew about this some
years ago and it didn't
seem to push them to stop them when it
came to giving this to autistic children
let's make this clear ryan that autistic
children have to drink this and they
also have to suffer
bleach enemas in a way to kind of cure
their condition which is not a disease
autism is not a disease that is a
neurodevelopmental condition
so even the wording is appalling so
while i
welcome what's happening at the moment i
just wish if they had done it sooner for
autism
covert has been kind of a green light to
kind of tackle this quackery but
arresting the grounds is not enough we
have carrie vera in germany
who is apparently being investigated by
the police but she has not been arrested
she is one of the
biggest players in the genesis 2 cult in
relation to bleaching autistic
children and then we have andreas calper
my real concern right now is south
america
ecuador mostly there are ten bishops of
the catholic church advocating this
as a cure for covert as we speak
it's amazing what desperate people will
believe fiona a question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
fiona you're talking about people taking
this that they believe it might kirakova
what is it that makes people
so desperate to try this so-called
miracle cure what's the
appeal well i think that in
countries like in south america or in
countries where scientific information
isn't readily available that people are
naive
and i suppose if they have somebody that
is plausible like
some members of this cult they come
across very scientific they say they're
doctors when they're not
they use bogus certificates to say i'm a
doctor and they're not really doctors
and then now we have the catholic church
and some representatives advocating
they feel huge influence on vulnerable
people and if you don't have much money
you know and if you can't get health
care this bleach isn't expensive you
know it's like 30 dollars
to take and facebook social media have
been advocating this for so many years
and there's so many groups on facebook
even right now that are
posing this as a cure for covert for
autism it's still there but not as much
because we've been so aggressive in
trying to shut it down but there's loads
of groups and pages on facebook
right now saying that the speech cures
code 19. so people believe it
and this whole idea that he's formed a
church and that these are the
sacraments of the church and gives them
a kind of protection that's really just
a fiction isn't it
well it's crazy i'm sorry this has got
nothing to do with religion
or god and they do this to circumvent
the law
to not pay taxes i mean i was shocked
actually brian i have received the court
papers in the last week in relation to
what they were making
and i was literally um i don't know i
was very traumatized to see that they've
made like nearly 130 000
last april selling bleach mostly to
people with comfort 19.
can you imagine having covered 19 and
not being able to breathe
than have to even smell these chemicals
and ingest them
it's it's abuse and it's torture and
i'm outraged that there are doctors and
you know representatives of the catholic
church thinking that this is the right
thing to give people
who are already suffering so much
and finally fiona we just have about 30
seconds left but you have been the
subject of much uh
harassment online haven't you for taking
the stand against the church
it's been a nightmare i mean every day i
get some kind of abuse in relation to
this
even recently mark brown especially has
been very aggressive towards me calling
me
a witch b-i-t-c-h um you know accusing
me of being mentally ill
he's uh said i am the child of a
motherless goat
he uses quotations from the bible to
abuse me but it doesn't bother me
because
i know what i'm doing is so important
especially for children
i've seen babies being given this bleach
recently in groups on facebook
i've seen breastfeeding mothers
ingesting this to prevent confident 19.
i'm calling on the pope actually to
address those bishops to stop spreading
this
bleach scam and i'm calling off facebook
to shut down all groups and pages to
protect people from this horrendous
bleach cult fianna larry thank you so
much for joining us really appreciate it
we asked mark grenon the archbishop if
he would appear in this program he said
he would never
talk with me all right coming up next
the election in this country is 16 weeks
away and some people claim it's already
being stolen by the republicans
see if you agree you're watching the law
and crime
trial network
well the november presidential election
is now just 16 weeks away and already in
the primaries we saw
all sorts of chaos at mayhem long lines
few polling places few polling workers
and many say the worst is yet to come
including an investigative journalist
who's written a provocative new book on
the subject
greg palace thank you so much for
joining us tonight i like the fedora
thank you i'll get you one
your book is out today how trump stole
the 2020 election
what's that all about the election
hasn't taken place yet
uh yeah yeah but it's already been
stolen the fix is in but we can unfix it
we can bust the burglary i don't want
people get this
the sparing i think that there's still a
chance that the voters will choose the
president instead of trickery
and uh so yeah so that's the big problem
and when you say he's already stolen
what do you mean
okay when i say he it's the
it's the vote thieving tricksters in the
past couple of years
we've had 16 million people
purge that is a race from the voter
rolls most people don't know that
they've lost their vote
and our experts have gone through these
purge lists in in several states and
found that about half are phony we've
had millions of people wrongly losing
their
right to vote you can by the way
reestablish your right to vote just go
online and check your registration i'm
telling people about that
because i don't want you to think it's
gone and lost forever no no
you're still an american citizen please
check your registration but 16 million
people have lost their vote
that's and unless they get it back we
already have a stolen election
in swing states like wisconsin for
example
in wisconsin they're trying to remove
152 000
voters the republican
legislature voted to remove these 152
000 voters on the grounds that they
moved you know look if you left
wisconsin brian you shouldn't be voting
in wisconsin if you left milwaukee you
shouldn't vote in milwaukee
but i went to milwaukee and i met with
one of the people that
was on the list of people who supposedly
left
milwaukee and i asked saquana taylor
have you left milwaukee and she said i
don't think so i'm a milwaukee county
supervisor
but she is african-american woman so the
targeting has gone
after young people and voters of color
and that's what i'm very very concerned
about we can reverse this but
at the moment the fix is in
you've done some great work on this
let's take a look at a clip where you
confronted then a georgia
secretary of state now governor brian
kemp about all of this
mr kemp are you removing black voters
from the voter rolls just so you can win
this election
please do not touch him
are you removing black voters just to
win this election please don't touch me
or i'll have your restaurant
are you why are you purging voters
to get the names of voters who've been
removed
and now greg what's the status in
georgia
well the status in georgia is the that
type of trickery
i actually had to sue that that guy
brian kemp to get the list of voters
he wants to remove from the voter rolls
and we want a federal court case
now we're going through that list and
we're finding a third of a million
voters were wrongly
removed from the voter rolls in georgia
including martin luther king's
92 year old cousin who they say had left
atlanta she's been living in the same
house
for half a century since martin luther
king used to come over
for sunday dinner this is what's
happening all over america so in
georgia is where they took the kind of
system of removing voters from the voter
rolls out for test drive it works so
well that they've taken it to ohio and
michigan and they're trying to bring it
into wisconsin
and several other states and that's what
i'm worried about
this is a mass attack on the voter rules
that's just one of the little tricks
that they can pull
and i'm very concerned that we've
already all these voters will not get
there
not get their mailing ballots and by the
way brian you can't get
mail in your ballot if it's not mailed
out to you and if you're not on the
voter rolls man
you ain't getting your ballot and
president trump has alleged uh mail-in
ballots will result in huge fraud
there's been no evidence of that
how do you see that issue well what i'm
worried about is fraud against the
voters
according to the in how trump stole 2020
i bring in the mit
caltech study which says 22
of all mail-in votes are never counted
that's one in five votes
how does that happen about one in 10
votes millions of votes
the voter doesn't get the ballot you
can't again you can't mail it
in if it's not mailed out to you so
there's all kinds of reasons why those
ballots don't get to you
but one in five ballots are not counted
and and
the other half of the missing ballots
are those that are mailed in about one
in ten mail in ballots
are disqualified and brian it's for all
kinds of cockamamie reasons you know
that 100
000 people lost their vote because of
postage due in 2016.
we had a quarter million people lose
their vote because they didn't have the
right
signature someone said they didn't have
the right signature
you used the wrong ballot stacey abrams
who
i was working with in georgia on these
voter purge systems an african-american
lead
you know voting rights leader she almost
lost her mail in ballot because
her ballot came to her in the primary
with the return ballot
in the georgia humidity the the envelope
was sealed
you break open that envelope you've lost
your vote
so these are the types of crazy things
that happen with mail-in voting
it's not it's not the voters who are
committing fraud
the tricksters are the voting officials
who are trying to make it difficult and
tough and disqual
on not sending you your ballot or
disqualifying your ballot beware
and but greg for the record have you
seen anywhere any evidence of fraud
involving uh voters who are committing
fraud with male imbalance
selling their violence or somehow
playing around with it
i actually did a calculation brian in
the book it's
and i found out i calculated that the
chance of your committing
mail-in ballot fraud is one-fifth as
likely
as being hit by lightning that's how
rare it is
we've been able to um from the rutgers
study found that
12 people committed voter impersonation
fraud
in six years that's out of several
billion
ballots cast but we do know
that literally millions of mail-in
ballots have been lost because people
didn't get them
etc so the fraud is this teeny-weeny
but the vote suppression the fancy word
for saying you didn't get your ballot or
they don't count it
that's that big
greg we've already seen the long lines
in the primaries across the country is
this going to be repeated in the general
election
is that part of the plan you think
unfortunately it
is exactly part of the plan that wasn't
a mistake you saw in georgia in kentucky
in wisconsin this is
the fact that people were standing in
line for hours do you think african
americans want to stand in line for
hours in a human reign
in atlanta and get a virus that could
kill them
no they didn't get their ballots and so
you had you
when we talked to the people in these
lines they requested absentee ballots
they didn't get them that's one of the
main reasons why people were
in line in these long terrible lines
plus with the virus
you can't get the you know we have older
people run the polls
they can't get poll workers because it's
just too dangerous for them to come in
so milwaukee we went from 180 polling
stations
to five in in an african-american city
in you know in louisville we went from
about
a couple hundred polling stations to one
this is going to be a disaster come
november unless
we prepare
greg let me ask you this is this an
argument perhaps to
postpone the election to delay it until
the virus has
passed somehow or the vaccine i
fear for democracy any delay i think is
very dangerous what we have to do is not
delay the fix
we've got a problem let's fix it
why we shouldn't be purging anyone from
voter rolls this year
no one should be losing their vote we
don't have any examples of
of people of aliens coming from outer
space
um you know we don't have dead voters we
don't see zombies we don't see ghost
voters we don't see people voting 28
times
this doesn't happen let's stop purging
voters
the second thing as a voter when you get
that mail-in ballot man
please look it over in some states you
you know
alabama you need a notarization of your
ballot and
or two witness signatures wisconsin
minnesota you need a witness signature
so i'm asking people just be
super careful with your ballot ask for
it really early
have someone check it over and if it
needs witness signatures
and we got crazy things you know that in
some states you have to mail in
photocopies of your id people miss this
and therefore we've had about 3 million
ballots mail-in ballots lost or
disqualified
that was in 16 multiply that by 10. we
can't lose 30 million ballots
brian we got to fix this now and i hope
not to delay the election
i hope not to delay the election but
rather to fix it
all right greg palace a terrific
investigative reporting on this subject
very much appreciate it
uh your book is out today how trump
stole a 2020
the hunt for america's vanished voters
greg palace thank you so much for
joining us tonight
you're very welcome brian
coming up one of the positives from the
coveted 19 pandemic a huge drop in the
crime rate
is there a way to keep it down we'll
talk to a leading expert
you're watching the law on crime trial
network
back now to talk about crime and ronda
schwartz one of the few positives to
come out of the pandemic
was a huge drop in the american crime
rate
that's right brian while we've seen a
big increase
in homicide shootings in major cities
over the last few weekends
a new study tracking crime in big cities
since the start of the pandemic
shows big decreases in other major
categories of crime
i guess not really a surprise and to get
more insight i talked earlier with
professor david abrams at the university
of pennsylvania school of law
professor abrams thank you so much for
joining us tonight in the midst of a
pandemic with demonstrations across
the country for racial and social
justice your studies found an amazing
fact about crime in this country
that's right brian we found that crime
has
dropped in response to the initial
incidents of the pandemic
and pretty much every city we looked at
with a couple
of exceptions and the drops were very
substantial
across most crime categories the biggest
one was drug crimes where declines were
about 60 percent
in the cities where we had data
and you think it's as simple as the fact
that people were not going outside i
think that is
one major component that has at least a
couple of effects
that individuals are less likely to be
targeted
especially for street crime when there
are fewer people on the street
but another piece is that they're less
likely to report crime and that's the
data that we're looking at
is reports of crime of course there's
another factor and that's
changes to policing and definitely
several major police departments made
the decisions to reprioritize
resources and especially to de-emphasize
certain
lower level types of crime so i think
that's
those factors put together explain a lot
of the changes we saw
in crime rates and again most are
declining with a couple
notable exceptions
in the past few weekends however we've
seen reports of extensive numbers of
shootings in new york and chicago and
elsewhere
does this fight your conclusion
it doesn't for a couple of reasons one
is the time period
we focus on for the study is mostly
ending around mid to end may so the
initial
interest is to look at largely the
pandemic
effects on crime but the second is
actually if we even
think about the more recent periods
going into
june and july a lot of times you see
spikes not just this year but in
many years in the spring and summer you
see spikes in especially homicides and
shootings violent crimes
there's just an annual trend to those
it's very difficult
to make very much of incidents that
happen in one week and or even a few
weekend you need more data you need to
look at a longer time horizon to be able
to say
something about what may have caused
those spikes
you're an economist by training as well
as a professor at the law school at the
university of pennsylvania
in new york congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez better known as aoc
offered her own explanation for what was
in new york a a spike in crime
listen to this and let's tell what you
think of her explanation
so why is this uptick in crime happening
well let's think about it
do we think this has to do with the fact
that there's record unemployment in the
united states right now
the fact that people are at a level of
economic desperation that we have not
seen since the great recession
maybe this has to do with the fact that
people aren't paying their rent and are
scared to pay their rent
and so they go out and they need to feed
their child
and they don't have money so you maybe
have to
you're they're put in a position where
they feel like they either need to
shoplift some bread
or go hungry that night um maybe it's
the fact that
unemployment provisions have not been
given to everyone maybe it's because the
fact that
people have some people still haven't
gotten their stimulus checks yet
so professor abrams does that make sense
to you as an explanation
well i think aoc has put forward an
intriguing hypothesis that's how
i as a academic economist would would
phrase that
and but one that there's not enough data
to
corroborate yet one weekend or even a
few weekends
doesn't tell us that what we'd want to
do to try to understand whether
unemployment and poverty are the reasons
behind some of the spikes in crime
is get a longer amount of data and we
want to look
at individuals who experience
unemployment they compare those with
those who did not that's the way
you can get a more meaningful
understanding
of the real causes of crime i'll just
add
when we looked at the hummus idea that
was actually one of the few of the
homicide in the shooting
data even earlier in the pandemic those
were two categories that we actually did
not see
a decline in crime during this period
but we also didn't see an
uptick as well and again it's because
it's hard to attribute changes unless
you have a good amount of data
also one thing we notice is that 2020
was a
high homicide and shooting year even
before the pandemic hit and
well before the protests and changes in
unemployment
so these things that look like they're
happening
now maybe more exacerbated now but that
may be just due to
standard seasonality we don't know yet
whether it's because of some of these
other causes
based on what you've seen do you think
that drop in crime is about to go back
up now that there is uh some reopening
at least in new york in the northeast
i do and we've already seen uh that
happen to some extent
uh if you look at the end of may and
then into june
at crime rates uh they have started
going back
up as people have started going back
outside
and getting i wouldn't say life is back
to normal
at all but somewhat closer to normal
crime is also going closer to back to
normal
but it seems that crime rates are for
many categories
are pretty well associated with people
being
outside and doing their regular routine
so as that continues
we'll see we'll probably i would expect
we'd probably see uh
increases in crime but to the extent we
have additional lockdowns
my guess is and and people concerned
about
uh the pandemic and staying home because
of it my guess is that will
correspond with uh lowering in crime
again
can we draw from your data that policing
matters less than outside circumstances
in terms of the crime rate
i wouldn't say that policing certainly
has an impact on the crime rate
and one of the possibilities that this
um
you know this the tragedy of the
pandemic holds though
is to increase our understanding of
causes
of and influences of crime uh overall
and not just in this setting that's one
of the
big goals i have for this research
project is to
take the circumstance where police
change
individual behaviors change surveillance
change
incentives to commit crime change and
try to see can we
try to take those pieces apart a little
bit and understand
uh better than we do now how much each
of those
impacts crime levels policing is
certainly one of them
but we need to study this more carefully
to try to
piece those apart you also have taken a
close look at calls for police reform
and
defunding the police with four
suggestions that you have made
including uh the union to stop
protecting bad officers
is that actually feasible do you think
i hope it's feasible um i will say one
thing that gives me a little bit
of maybe justification for that hope is
at least
in the instance of the floyd killing
there was not
the immediate reaction of police unions
across the country
to defend those officers and that's
something we've seen
even in other particularly uh egregious
incidents of incontinent videotape so
that
by and large i think with maybe minimal
exception didn't happen this time
what i've heard from police unions makes
me think that they are
open to uh to more negotiation now into
more
responsiveness to what seems to be
popular popular
requests these days for more
accountability for police departments
um and uh and policing that
accords better with what uh what people
in their cities
uh prefer and can you tell us what you
think would be the consequence of the
so-called defunding movement
in terms of the crime rate and safety
and security and
frankly law and order as some have
called for sure
and the defunding movement as i
understand it
first of all suffers from a major
marketing problem
my understanding is most uh sane people
who are calling for defunding the police
don't want to get rid of the police
completely and don't want to get rid of
all their funding
i think they want substantial change to
it and i think that is a popular
sentiment
now is this likely to happen
i hope so and i think there is real
scope for it
happening i know there's discussion
there already bill's been passed a
number of different cities
aimed at partly is literally decreasing
funding for police but also
the possibility of assigning some of the
police functions for example
dealing with homeless people to
different
parties and individuals with different
types of training
i think this is all this all can be
helpful but i
do think that just decreasing
funding to the police without any
alternative
is not the way to go there's pretty good
evidence that
police do decrease crime and i don't
think anyone wants crime to spike
anywhere and so the question is how to
do
how to make reforms that change
policing so that we have we don't have
say unwarranted stops of individuals we
don't have
racial disparities in policing but we do
still have
effective policing and i think one
important piece of that is
having better individual accountability
for officers especially in supervisory
roles
all right well professor david abrams
thank you so much from fascinating
insights from your data
which is really important trying to
figure out what's going on in the real
world
yeah absolutely agree and i can't
emphasize
that enough i'm glad you mentioned it
because without data
we don't know what's going on at all and
there was just a story about
the chicago police department
restricting access to
arrest data in response to a story that
wasn't popular with them
you know i think that's just the wrong
direction to go and i think the more
you know the more data fortunately most
cities are moving the direction of
more data rather than less i think
that's a great thing
all right professor evans thank you
again for being here tonight
thanks so much
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media as chosen by the editors of
mediaite tucker carlson
on the hot seat you're watching the law
and crime trial network
and we close out our program tonight
with this week's winners and losers in
the media
joined as always by aiden mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and aiden
cnn broke a big story over the weekend
about the head writer
at tucker carlson's program at fox news
lots came from that
yeah so this story got broken by cnn
media reporter oliver darcy on friday
night
uh actually you know an hour or so
before tucker carlson was going to
go on air to do his primetime show on
fox news and uh it it revealed that the
head writer of tucker carlson's show
who has been the head writer for the
show for for some a few years now
um had been posting these racist and
sexist comments
uh pretty pretty viciously racist and
sexist comments
on an obscure messaging board for years
now you know since then the writer
resigned
uh fox news had to issue a statement
condemning the comments made by the
writer
and then just last night tucker carlson
actually addressed
the resignation on air and delivered i
wouldn't call it an apology but he
he addressed the uh the resignation and
the comments and at least gave his
thoughts on it
i think we have video of that first what
blake wrote anonymously was wrong
we don't endorse those words they have
no connection to the show
it is wrong to attack people for
qualities they cannot control
in this country we judge people for what
they do not for how they were born
we often say that because we mean it
we'll continue to defend that principle
often alone among national news programs
because it is essential nothing is more
important
blake fell short of that standard and he
has paid a very heavy price for it
but we should also point out to the
ghouls now beating their chests in
triumph of the destruction of a young
man
that self-righteousness also has its
costs
we are all human when we pretend we are
holy
we are lying when we pose as blameless
in order to hurt other people
we are committing the gravest sin of all
and we will be punished for it
there's no question and aiden in tucker
carlson's explanation of what his
thoughts were
he didn't really go into what it was
that blake neff his writer
said on these sites actually using an
anonymous name right he used a different
name than his own
yes he was under a pseudonym and what i
thought was pretty shocking about
tucker's comments there is that he
seemed to express more anger at
uh the reporting and the reaction to
blake neff's
uh comments written on this uh messaging
board than the comments themselves
which were really i should note you know
i'm not gonna repeat any of them here
but they were really
viciously racist and sexist um there was
one
comment uh sort of thread where he
basically harassed a woman that he knew
over facebook
for years uh with thousands of comments
uh directing harassment
at this this woman's looks uh and other
you know features
and that's aside from all the racist
stuff that was posted here
um so the the idea that you know fox
news has to come out
they take the resignation of this lead
writer they issue a statement calling
his
behavior horrendous calling the comments
horrific and then tucker carlson doesn't
reveal to his audience what the nature
of those comments were
and basically you know condemns the
cnn for reporting on them uh is fairly
shocking
and uh i'm sure it's not the sort of
contrition that fox news executives
would have liked to extend
and i think a larger question here is is
there evidence that what blake neff
thought
in person or personally on these sites
worked its way into tucker carlson's
broadcast on fox news
yeah i think there's a lot of evidence
of that uh oliver darcy that again the
reporter who wrote the cnn story
actually uh pointed out a couple of the
similarities in the language between
the stuff that he was posting on this
messaging board and some of tucker
carlson's monologues
um he also revealed blake nap in a
piece in an interview he did with the
dartmouth review uh that he
was wrote the first draft for all of
tucker carlson's monologues
and a lot of the scripts that went up on
the show so he really was the lead
writer
and you know tucker carlson has actually
fended off accusations
of that his show is racist for years now
uh you know he's done
he's gotten into hot water for uh asking
why diversity
is inherently a good thing uh for saying
that white nationalism the idea
that that is prevalent in the united
states is a hoax uh and whenever he gets
accused of racism
he dismisses it and says that you know
that's absurd that's ridiculous
uh it makes it a lot harder for him to
claim that his show
is the ideas that his show promotes are
not racist now
when we know that the person that was
writing it was for years
posting incredibly racist things on a
messaging board
so i think a lot of the plausible
deniability is is gone now for tucker
carlson
um and that might explain why this week
he's gone on vacation
uh he announced last night on his show
uh after he
uh issued those comments on on blake
knapp that he was going uh
on a pre-planned he said trip to go
trout fishing
this week um which the network says that
has
was always uh on the cards um but of
course it's not the first time their fox
news host
has gone on vacation after they've
become mired in controversy
and we'll see if he comes back of course
fox news that's the number one
cable news network and tucker carlson
with the number one show on that network
uh gets a lot of attention but so does
another uh
anchor at fox news chris wallace who you
called a winner for his take
in his great interview last sunday with
the secretary of education
betsy devos let's take a look at that
but secretary i want to get i want to
get to this issue
of because this the president of the
united states said that the cdc
guidelines were tough
expensive and impractical i want to look
at some of the other
cdc guidance they talked about putting
up
shielding in places where six foot six
feet of distance is not possible
plastic shielding they talked about
staggered
drop-offs and pickups is that
tough expensive and impractical
so aidan in your view and the view of
your editors at media what made that a
winning
interview sure so betsy devos did a
couple
interviews this weekend on the sunday
shows um but we really thought that
chris wallace's
interrogation of her was the best one
he's
he's
he's very very good chris wallace he's
the host of uh fox news sunday
he's extremely good at holding officials
feet to the fire
i think that's what we tune in to watch
him for when you know it doesn't matter
whether it's a trump official
or you know an official in the you know
new york government
he's extremely good at interrogating uh
people in power
and uh you know trying to discern uh
whether or not either they're telling
the truth
or they're being fair or whatnot and uh
his interview with betsy devos was was
really
compelling uh and he questioned her on
president donald trump's comments about
schools reopening in the fall
and whether or not they passed muster um
a lot of which his comments about sort
of the cdc guidelines about schools
opening
uh were sort of absurd and you know it's
kind of hard to ask president donald
trump about these things especially when
trump hasn't granted chris wallace an
interview in years uh but the
ability to be able to question betsy
devos on these on these
uh issues is a really important one and
he did a really good job of it
so from a broad perspective does this
speak well of the operation at fox news
that they have
all kinds of controversy going on with a
wide range of views it seems or at least
some range of views you know it's
actually quite a tricky question for
them
they often use uh anchors like chris
wallace
shep smith when he was still at the
network uh to point
to the fact that they have real news
people working for the network and that
they have
you know news bonafide uh particularly
they
they point to chris wallace whenever uh
one of their opinion hosts
uh becomes gets into controversy whether
it's for being too
tight with the administration or uh you
know another issue
so i you know they're often wielded as
uh
sort of evidence that fox news is a very
serious news network and i think it's a
it's a strong argument um i don't know
if it convinces critics of fox news
and 15 seconds here eight and uh what
does fox news say when you call about
uh mr uh carlson
uh i i you know he's the top rated host
on fox news i
he's not going anywhere i think we can
confidently say
so you think he'll be back from his uh
trout fishing vacation
even with fewer advertisers yeah you
know i think advertisers for a while
have drifted away from his show
fox news still makes a huge amount of
money from it he's replaced
sean hannity at least in the recent
month as the top-rated host on fox news
um so i think they're pretty confident
that he's definitely
all right aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much as always and thanks for the team
here at law and crime for getting us on
the air
and off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you